alguna vez has pensado cómo se comunican
las diferentes partes de tu cuerpo
a menudo creemos que el cuerpo es esta
cosa completa una unidad sin embargo la
realidad es que nuestro cuerpo está
compuesto de muchas partes en el cuerpo
existen muchos sistemas de órganos cada
uno de ellos formado por varios órganos
y cada uno de esos órganos está hecho de
tejidos y cada uno de esos tejidos está
hecho de células es una locura tenemos
aproximadamente 100 billones de células
en nuestro cuerpo entonces no es curioso
cómo se pueden comunicar esas 100
billones de partes diferentes bueno la
primera forma es a través del sistema
nervioso y a través de pistas
preestablecidas de nervios pero no todo
el cuerpo está conectado por los nervios
por ejemplo cómo es que parte del
cerebro se comunicaría con parte del
riñón bueno para hablar
yo tenemos que hablar del sistema
endocrino
el sistema endocrino es un sistema de
órganos llamados glándulas y las
glándulas secretan pequeños mensajes
químicos que se llaman hormonas y
liberan estos pequeños mensajes químicos
llamados hormonas en el torrente
sanguíneo así pueden circular de una
parte del cuerpo a otra para iniciar un
efecto existen muchas partes del cuerpo
que usan estas hormonas para comunicarse
pero ciertos órganos están realmente
definidos por este método de
comunicación y los llamamos glándulas
endocrinas una de las glándulas
endocrinas más importantes es el
hipotálamo el hipotálamo se localiza
justo aquí es parte del diente falo y
como parte del cerebro recibe muchas
señales desde el sistema nervioso por lo
tanto estas señales nerviosas se
canalizan en el cerebro
entonces el hipotálamo como una especie
de miembro dual del sistema endocrino
canaliza estas señales a la glándula
pituitaria debido a que juega ese doble
papel entre el sistema endocrino y el
sistema nervioso a menudo el hipotálamo
tiene como misión ser el centro de
control del sistema endocrino además de
estimular la glándula pituitaria el
hipotálamo también hace sus propias
hormonas produce a dh y oxitocina a de h
por sus siglas en inglés es la hormona
antidiurética la cual es un principal
regulador del volumen de los fluidos en
nuestro cuerpo por su parte la oxitocina
es una hormona que estimula las
contracciones del útero femenino durante
el parto
este es el hipotálamo un miembro del
cerebro y del sistema endocrino donde
todo comienza él es el centro de control
debajo del hipotálamo tenemos la
glándula pituitaria esta glándula
también conocida como hipófisis cuelga
justo debajo del hipotálamo el
hipotálamo tiene el tamaño de una uva
mientras que la glándula pituitaria
tiene el tamaño de un chícharo pero este
chícharo es muy importante por ello se
le conoce como la glándula maestra y se
le conoce así porque la glándula
pituitaria toma el estímulo recibido del
hipotálamo y lo dirige a todas las otras
glándulas endocrinas o al menos a casi
todas las otras glándulas endocrinas de
tal modo que su función depende del
trabajo correcto de la glándula
pituitaria por lo tanto
este pequeño chicharrón es una parte muy
importante del sistema endocrino una de
las glándulas que la pituitaria dirige
es la glándula tiroides que se localiza
justo aquí en tu cuello envuelve la
tráquea de hecho puede sentir la
tiroides en tu cuello al tragar si pones
las manos alrededor de tu manzana de
adán y tragas esa cosa carnosa que se
mueve arriba y abajo es la tiroides la
tiroides tiene como trabajo principal
regular el metabolismo de tu cuerpo y lo
hace a través de las hormonas tiroideas
t3 y t4 otro nombre de la hormona de
tres estrellado tirón y lahm y otro
nombre de t4 stroke sin a la tiroides
usa estas hormonas para estimular el
metabolismo del cuerpo lo cual es
crucial para que el cuerpo obtenga
energía justo detrás de la glándula
tiroides tenemos cuatro puntos que se
les conoce colectivamente
como glándulas paratiroides el rol
principal de la para tiroides es regular
el nivel de calcio en la sangre el nivel
de calcio en la sangre es sumamente
importante porque el calcio hace muchas
cosas en nuestro cuerpo está involucrado
en las contracciones musculares está
involucrado en el crecimiento de los
huesos y estas funciones son muy
sensibles al nivel de calcio que se
encuentra en nuestra sangre así que la
glándula para tiroides es decir estos
cuatro puntos en la parte posterior de
la tiroides regulan el calcio a través
de la hormona paratiroidea o [ __ ] h por
sus siglas en inglés ahora si nos
movemos hacia abajo hasta el torso
tenemos las glándulas suprarrenales
éstas se encuentran en la parte superior
de los riñones y se llaman suprarrenales
porque están justo arriba del sistema
urinario que a veces es llamado sistema
renal
las glándulas suprarrenales se dividen
en dos partes la parte interna y la
externa la parte externa es la corteza y
la interna es la médula la razón de esta
distinción es que la parte interna y la
externa de la glándula suprarrenal
tienen distintas funciones primero en la
parte externa o la corteza se hacen los
esteroides es decir los corticosteroides
suprarrenales los dos ejemplos más
importantes de esteroides hechos en la
corteza suprarrenal son el cortisol y la
aldosterona el cortisol es una de las
hormonas del estrés del cuerpo es decir
aumenta el azúcar en la sangre en
momentos de estrés para obtener energía
además de tener una función
antiinflamatoria por otra parte la
aldosterona es una de las hormonas
reguladoras principales del volumen
sanguíneo en nuestro cuerpo
es decir cuánto fluido hay en nuestras
venas y arterias después tenemos a la
médula la médula crea una clase de
hormonas llamadas catecolaminas los dos
ejemplos más importantes de
catecolaminas son la epinefrina y la
norepinefrina a veces a la epinefrina se
le conoce como adrenalina y tal vez con
este nombre que sea más familiar estás
catecolaminas están involucradas en la
respuesta del cuerpo de lucha o huida la
adrenalina responde a los momentos en
que estamos estresados o asustados
entonces la glándula suprarrenal está
conformada de la médula y la corteza
ahora si seguimos con la lista y nos
movemos más abajo en el cuerpo tenemos
las gónadas en las mujeres
estos son los ovarios y en los hombres
los testículos las gónadas liberan las
hormonas sexuales en los hombres los
testículos producen testosterona
y en las mujeres los ovarios producen
estrógeno y progesterona pero estas
hormonas sexuales están involucradas
principalmente en el desarrollo de
nuevas características sexuales
secundarias como el vello púbico un
cuerpo más robusto en los varones o el
aumento de busto en las mujeres además
estas hormonas están involucradas en
nuestro proceso en las distintas etapas
de la vida que acompañan estas
características sexuales como la
pubertad o la menopausia
y por último pero no por eso menos
importante tenemos al páncreas el cual
se localiza en la parte superior del
abdomen y dejamos el páncreas para el
final porque no se involucra
directamente con la glándula pituitaria
como las otras hormonas endocrinas pero
usa esas hormonas para estimular el
efecto en una parte distinta del cuerpo
el efecto que estimula el páncreas es el
control sobre el azúcar en la sangre y
lo hace a través de las hormonas
insulina y glucagón
el páncreas es muy importante porque sin
sus hormonas la insulina y el glucagón
no podemos regular cuánta azúcar hay en
la sangre en comparación de la cantidad
de células y por eso puede conducir a
enfermedades graves como la diabetes así
que con el páncreas podemos concluir la
lista de las glándulas endocrinas más
importantes podemos ver estas glándulas
y estas hormonas y pensar en todos los
distintos efectos que producen en tu
cuerpo además nos queda bastante claro
que no son sólo unas pocas hormonas las
que circulan por nuestra sangre hay
muchísimas hormonas circulando a través
de nuestro sistema vascular en todo
momento esto nos plantea un posible
problema si estamos en el cerebro e
intentamos decirle algo al riñón
entonces le mandamos un mensaje que
soltaremos en la sangre
como sabemos que le llegará es decir no
es eso lo que todas las glándulas
endocrinas están intentando hacer bueno
resulta que las hormonas son muy
parecidas a las ondas de radio en tu
ciudad o en tu pueblo existen varias
estaciones de radio distintas que ponen
muchas canciones diferentes al mismo
tiempo e incluso tal vez desde la ciudad
más próxima existan ondas de radio
llenando el aire de tu ciudad pero una
vez que hemos sintonizado la estación
específica no vamos a recibir las otras
estaciones que estén siendo transmitidas
de una manera muy parecida una hormona
no será recibida a menos que exista un
receptor muy específico en la célula
objetivo entonces el receptor y su
ubicación son muy importantes para
determinar la función de una hormona y
tenemos distintas categorías que nos
sirven para identificar qué hormonas
sirve para cada función la primera
categoría son las hormonas auto green as
ellas actúan en la misma célula que la
sintetizó un ejemplo de ellas son los
linfocitos de del sistema inmunológico
ellos secretan una hormona llamada
interleucina que manda una señal a la
célula misma para aumentar su
efectividad y su función inmune la
segunda categoría son las hormonas para
crías y ellas actúan de forma regional
un ejemplo de ellas puede ser las
hormonas que libera el hipotálamo para
dar instrucciones a la glándula
pituitaria por último tenemos la tercera
categoría que son las hormonas
endocrinas estas son las hormonas que
actúan a distancia un ejemplo puede ser
la glándula pituitaria que estimula a
las gónadas a gran distancia entonces
tenemos las categorías auto crines para
crin as endocrinas
que nos ayudan a determinar la función
de la hormona aunque hemos estudiado
bastante sobre las hormonas en este
vídeo recordemos que es la introducción
a una de las formas más importantes en
las que se comunican las 100 billones de
partes diminutas e individuales de todo
tu cuerpo